مساء الخير جميعا بدايه نعرفكم عن حالي
انا لما زكريا طالب في كليه الهندسه
المعماريه وعملت 22 سنه عشت في بيئه
متعلمه وجيده كل واحد كانوا مواظب على
انجاز ما او موهبه معه اخواتي مثلا كانوا
ابطال العرب برياضه المبارزه وفعلا كنت عم
امشي على مسارهم ولما وصلت على اعتاب
تمثيل المنتخب السوري للمبارزه للاسف بلشت
الحرب مثل كثير من الشباب يلي كانوا عندهم
احلام وطموحات وما قدرت تكمل نتيجه الظروف
اللي صارت والاوضاع هي ان فرضت علينا كل
ما نمشي خطوه طبيعيه واحده لقدام منلاقي
100 عقبه ترجعنا الف خطوه لوراء وصار جل
اهتمام نمرق يومنا براحه وهدوء وحتى هذا
الشيء كان يعتبر
الرفاهيه بذكر لما كنت اجتماع مع رفقاتي
او حتى لما قابل اي شخص جديد كان ينتبهي
الفضول واساله فورا شو فكر تعمل لقدام كان
الجواب حتما السفر ليش يمكن الشعور بالعجز
انه نحن اشخاص ما بحق انه نحلم لا هذا
المكان مكاننا ولا حد هذا الزمان زماننا
القلم والضغوطات والمعاناه والمسؤوليات
الكبيره اللي عم نحملها شاب بعمل عشرين او
حتى الثلاثين كانت كفيل انه هي تقتل شغف
هي اللي جواته يدور على طريق تاني لحتى هو
يحاول يثبت حاله ويحس حاله هو شخص عايش
وموجود على هذه الحياه
بعده مريت بفتت البكالوريا يمكن يلي هي
تعتبر من اصعب الفترات على الطالب مرحله
مصيريه عم يفكر بمستقبله وين رايح وشو بده
يعمل وشو راح يصير
صار معي وقتها موقف كتير لطيف كنت عم ادرس
العلوم وتحديدا بفتره التكميله البكالوريا
شردت بلشت ارسم دوائر وزخارف وتفاصيل على
طرف الكتاب رغم بساطه الرسم لانه هي كانت
كتير جميله بالنسبه لالي وبعد فتره بشوف
رسمه كتير لمشابهه يلي رسمته على الفيسبوك
ومكتوب عليها فن الماندالا يلي بيعني فن
من اصول هنديه بيحتوي على دوائر واشكال
هندسيه وكميات هائله من التفاصيل والزخارف
وهون حسيت هالفن فعلا كتير بيشبهني واللي
اول مره اشعر بانتماء المطلق اتجاه فعل او
فكره كان دائما اخي نبهني على فكره مهم
تحس بالانتماء بحياتك سواء كان له فعل
لفكره او حتى العمل هذا الانتماء يا بتكبر
بيكبر معك او بنزلك وبدمرك
بلشت تعرف بهذا الفن وابحث عنه اكثر واكثر
وكانت تعلم كلياته بشكل ذاتي لانه للاسف
ما كان في مراكز تعليميه بسوريا ملمه بهذا
الفن
وصلت الى درجه لا باس بها من الاحترافيه
بعد سنتين تقريبا وهون باخد اولى خطواتي
بهذا المجال شاركت بمعرض نساء صغيرات
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وبعدها شاركت بمعارض على المستوى المحلي
ولكن رجع شعور روتيني بالملل انا تعلمت
وبعدين شو لسا ممكن اعمل كنت كتير شوف
اشخاص ملهمين ومبدعين على السوشيال ميديا
محققين انجازات هائله انجازات رهيبه كان
بيخطرني نحن ليش ما بنكون مثل هذه الاشخاص
وكانت فكره من ضرب الخيال انه يحاول ادخل
جينيس من هون من سوريا وخاصه بمجال الفني
رحت واقترحت على اهلي الفكره
[موسيقى]
وقدموا لي دعم معنوي كتير كبير ودعم مادي
كثير كبير وفعلا ب 2020 من مرسمه الصغير
يلي بتتجاوز مساحته ال15 متر مربع اشتغلت
على اكبر لوحه ماندلا بالعالم بمساحه 25
متر مربع
4,096 دائره هو الاف الملايين من النقاط
كان جهد جبار كتير انه يحاول اخلق 4000
دائره بناء على لجنه كيف دائره تكون
مختلفه عن الثانيه وما يكون في تشابه
بيناتهم وفعلا لما وصلت ل 3,400 اضطرت انا
هون وقف شهرين لانه نفذت عندي كل الافكار
كل ما احس قربت توصل وراح انهي الفكره
وراح انهي الموضوع لاقي في عقبه قدامي بس
كان الشغف يلي جواتهم والانتماء العملي
اكبر بكثير
ايام كنت ارسم برد وايام كنت ارسم بايام
بقطعه كهرباء ايام ما قدر وزن بين دراسه
الاكاديميه هندسه العماره وبين محاوله
الموسوعه جينيس انا كتير بحب لوحدي بس
بكره الظروف اللي كنت عم ارسم فيها اللوحه
وفعلا استغرق الموضوع حوالي سنتين
وانهيت رسم اللوحه ب 26/11/2021 برفع
الادله للجنه
وكان المفروض هون انطر ثلاثه شهور لحتى
توصلني النتيجه يعني هالثلاثه شهور كانوا
من اصعب واطول الاشهر بحياتي وانا ناطره
النتيجه ويا ترى انا رح وصل ولا لا
ولكن للاسف كان في اخطاء تقنيه مرتكبتها
وللاسف
كان هون شعور الياس والعجز كتير كبير
انه انا خلص رح وقف ساعت كتير وحاولت كثير
وكانت الموضوع جدا صعب وجدا جدا جدا كبير
كل ما احاول امشي خطوه لقدام لاقيه في
عقبه اكبر منه والموضوع استنزف مني كثير
جهد ما ضل فيني جلد ولا ابدا لحتى اخذ
خطوه واحده لقدام
بس بوقتها كان في جيش كتير عظيم من اهلي
واخواتي
اللي حسسوني بلحظات الياس والعجز انه لما
حلمك لحالك لازم تحققيه وهذا مو انجازك
لحالك هذا حلمنا كلياتنا وهذا انجزنا
كلياتنا فحملوني هاي المسؤوليه ضعفين
وفعلا كملت
وفي عشره خمسه 2022
الساعه وحده ونصف بالليل فقت راح اشرب مي
اشعار من مكتوب
تهانينا انت حامل لقب جنس الحالي باكبر
لوحه مالها بالعالم
[تصفيق]
يعني الشعور اللي حسيته بوقتها من فخر
وعظمه من سعاده من امتنان وقوه رح تضل
مقصره بوصف حق هذا الشعور لاول مره بحس
حالي انه انا شخص بلشت تحس انه عايش موجود
بهذا المكان وقدروا توصل للعالميه ومن هون
من سوريا
المحل كمان ونحن كلياتنا عنا احلام وعنا
طموحات عم نحاول نسعى لالها وفي عقبات
كتير كبيره قدامنا
تعلمت بالمبارزه وانه ما رح يطلع معي احسن
ما عندي الا لما يكون خصم كثير قوي وتعلمت
بالماندالا لانه الظروف الصعبه اللي صارت
معنا ما كان طلع معي هذا الشيء بس الفرق
الوحيد اللي صار وانه بالمبارزه كانت
مواجهتي مع الخصم اما قبل ما كانت مواجهتي
مع الذات حسيت انه فعلا هذا الالم اللي عم
حسه هو الم عبقري يلي عم يقدر يطلع الشيء
اللي جواتنا ويتحول لشيء عبقري او حتى
ابداعي اكيد كلياتنا عنا احلام وطموحات
سواء
الافضل شيخ بالعالم افضل مصور بالعالم
ونحن من حقنا نحلم ونوصل العالميه كشباب
سوريين يمكن حياتنا مثل ما كنا متخيلين
نحن وصغار انه لما نحط هدف قدامنا بنعتقد
كل المقومات اللي بالحياه تصب معنا
وتدعمنا لحتى نوصل بس الشغف والانتماء
والحب للعمل هو الشيء الاساسي لحتى الواحد
يقدر يكمل وشكرا
[تصفيق]